it's 5:00 a.m. and today for the first
time I'm going to go diving with sharks
everyone thinks that these creatures are
man-eaters you know they're stunning
they're beautiful so to be in their
world and watch them dominate and for me
to be on the backfoot you just go yeah
go tread carefully
I'm not just diving with any shark
the bull shark is one of the most
dangerous in the world responsible for
more attacks on humans than any other
species of shark
see me we're heading out to a dive spot
known appropriately as the big scare
my dive buddy his vandals all made
Daniel side by side right
anything become aggressive one
the tank
like without morning's I see this brief
three
bull sharks have a tendency to headbutt
their prey before attacking
I've been told that my first glimpse
would be a big dark shadow then suddenly
at three meters it's as big as a minibus
even these fearsome creatures are not
immune to being slaughtered for their
fins they too are facing a high risk of
extinction as a visitor in their
environment you realize just what is at
stake sharks are the kingpin of the
marine food chain have we take them away
our oceans will be damaged forever
that was incredible there today I mean
beyond incredible in a way that it was
their territory their their domain and
we were we we were just sat there in awe
and also even with that short sort of
you know time with them you just hands
up Jemaine I can leave them alone
total respect leave them alone and
respect their beauty